mmm had a rough one yesterday after I
saw you rough one I got in a fight but
yeah I didn't up you add in another
street fight to your bill I I don't even
like talking about this and I don't want
to talk about it how many is this a
thousand it's a lot it's enough
don't be a dick dude I'm I'm not man I
know but I got it you know I'm not gonna
if I tell you that I you're gonna go
yeah I got a night it's not funny it was
United of a sinful yeah I got in a
scuffle and you're sore from it yeah I'm
sore from a longer the scuffle that you
know street fight really lasts less than
60 yeah and this lasted you want I mean
you're gonna be a dick God just be
honest you want to know how long it
lasted yes with with every with the
chase and everything oh there is a chase
car chase or foot chase both don't be a
dick Mike yeah alright nice like yeah so
I'm driving I'll do you want to hear it
you got to give me the plot from Grand
Theft Auto I'm not gonna give you the
problem driving and minding my own
business I'm on the the right hand lane
and a guy drives by this woman in her
SUV and takes his bike lock and smashes
her window well calls her a [ __ ] well
and she starts to cry and he takes off
down the way but I'm all the way on the
other side so I have to cut I just
instinctually go I go stay there and she
was like you said that to her
yeah did you ask her what she did wrong
I could tell that she did nothing wrong
cuz she goes I didn't do anything on the
situation she goes I didn't do anything
wrong and I go I know stay there captain
save-a-ho was here alright I'm sorry
captain save-a-ho I'm trying to tell
story bro I'm real idling this is in
Venice yeah it's in Venice right I don't
know I got nedk so I make a I make a
ride I shrug brought us all traffic and
I chase him down the way and I'm trying
to I'm trying he's on a bike and I'm
chasing him he's on a bike in my Tesla
oh wow and so he's moving pretty quickly
and I I go pull out I go pull over and
then he goes [ __ ] you
is he on like a huffy or Harley he's all
right no he's on a huffy
okay like your bike so he pulls in like
clip his wheel goes down so I pull over
and I jump out and it he gives chase
what up well don't say Gibbs chase he is
he why I left so I left
so he's white he's white with Prison
tattoos everywhere and he was a big guy
probably wife beater tattoos yeah rough
yeah yeah it said like sweats hate yep
yep yep yep and so I left upon him and
as I left upon him he swung his [ __ ]
so I left here I well he like jumped on
them like belly
neither belly need about here okay and
then he hold my coffee he grabbed me
around my hips here okay okay get up and
then I then he brought his hands up and
he [ __ ] put him around my dad yep
like this and then I was like this so
yeah they're doing yeah and we were like
this okay and then he he goes he goes he
goes I'm kiss you showing you the point
is I got enough [ __ ] funny man
sorry [ __ ] sorry I know how do you
think I felt man he had a full beard you
lucky in [ __ ] yeah
well he tried trying to make it out with
you I heard whoa yeah goatee I what the
[ __ ] in his shirt we had a pitbull
that tried to bite oh my godness so I
had to ice lead a dog they'll have
another girl the girl I came back back
yep and she was going 1 to 10 what she
looked like she was in [ __ ] the tent
try hooking her up she goes James her
real I was like what and she showed me
her breasts girl marriage she goes I
won't tell I go no way I'm married no
way and then she goes just touch him
yeah you go do what you know justice
it's just it's justice I held them in my
hands for a while just shield oh wait is
your titty [ __ ] off me no no that would
be all mother here it would be cheating
or it's what heroes do well it is what
heroes do but Bruce Wayne does I was
like I was like you earned this yes yeah
hey guys I'm together I'll put this
justice pipe between them did you say
captain save-a-ho
yeah I did yeah heard that before no
it's very famous right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]